on average wildfires burn up to five
million acres of land in the United
States each year while they can start
naturally wildfires are often caused by
humans with devastating consequences
wildfires are large uncontrolled
infernos that burn and quickly spread
through wild landscapes types of
wildfires may include forests brush and
peat land fires depending on the
landscapes affected wildfires require
three components known as the fire
triangle a heat source fuel and oxygen
heat sources such as the Sun a hot bolt
of lightning or a smoldering match can
supply enough heat to spark a fire that
spark then turns into flames when fuel
or any flammable material is present dry
dead grasses leaves and trees are common
fuels for wildfires but so are living
vegetation called green fuels pine trees
and other evergreens contain flammable
oils that can burn when exposed to a
heat source as the fuel burns the
resulting flames feed and thrive off of
oxygen when air movement or wind occurs
not only is more oxygen supplied to the
fire but it may also help transport and
spread the flames
since wildfires occur outdoors they have
a nearly endless supply of oxygen from
our atmosphere to burn many wildfires
are the result of natural causes a
warmer climate and weather patterns like
El Nino can create the hot dry
conditions necessary for fires to erupt
however about 90% of wildfires are
caused by human activity such as camp
fires that become uncontrollable
improperly handled cigarettes or arson
although wildfires occur worldwide they
are most common in the western United
States their high temperatures droughts
and frequent lightning and thunderstorms
can create the perfect setting for
wildfires while they can be destructive
and sometimes even deadly for humans
wildfires do play an important role in
nature they can help a forest by
removing harmful insects or diseased
plants and they can clear thick canopies
to help sunshine reach seedlings on a
forest floor by being aware of the
conditions necessary for wildfires to
occur they can be managed and prevented
thereby saving lives and making way for
the positive effects of wildfires
[Music]